Resuelve "x" y nos están dando esta igualdad. Tenemos 8 que multiplica el valor absoluto de "x" más 7,
más 4 que es igual a -6 que multiplica el valor absoluto de "x" más 7 más 6.
Vamos a reescribir esta ecuación de tal manera que nuestros valores absolutos, bueno,
brinquen y destallen y los veamos
muchísimo más fácil.
Tendremos entonces 8 que multiplica el valor
absoluto de "x" más 7
y a eso le suma una constante que pondremos con anaranjado que será el más 4.
Todo esto será igual a -6 que multiplica
el valor absoluto de "x" más 7
y que a su vez está sumado por más 6.
Tenemos en verde los factores que están
multiplicando el valor absoluto
y en anaranjado tenemos las constantes.
Vamos entonces a hacer algo.
Esto se ve tal vez muy complicado,
pero lo que haremos y les propongo es,
que despejemos primero este valor
absoluto de "x" más 7,
para así podernos hacer más sencilla la vida y verán que bueno,  despejar entonces "x" será rapidísimo.
Si nosotros tenemos una igualdad y tenemos aquí escrito que es una igualdad,
para que nosotros nos podamos deshacer de este -6 valor absoluto de "x" más 7,
lo que haremos es sumarle a este lado
un +6 valor absoluto de "x" más 7.
Ojo, como esto es una igualdad, debemos de hacer exactamente el mismo procedimiento en ambos lados,
así es que si de este lado hemos sumado,
+6 valor absoluto de "x" más 7,
pues del lado izquierdo sumaremos también +6 valor absoluto de "x" más 7, vamos bien.
Ahora vamos a pasar las constantes del
lado derecho de la igualdad,
por lo que si tenemos aquí un +4 y yo lo quiero quitar de este lado, lo que haré es restar, menos 4,
pero como lo hice del lado izquierdo para no afectar la igualdad, también restaré del lado derecho,
menos 4, vamos a poner el signo de la igualdad...
¿esto a qué nos lleva?
Tendremos entonces, de los dos lados, lo siguiente,
y aquí tenemos -6 valor absoluto de "x" más 7 que le estamos sumando 6 valor absoluto de 7,
por lo que estos se eliminan.
Y tendremos 6 menos 4, es igual a 2.
Vamos del otro lado.
4 menos 4 se eliminan y esto fue a propósito,
¿recuerdan?
Y entonces aquí sumaremos,
podemos considerar este valor absoluto de "x" más 7 como una variable, ok,
si tenemos 8 de algo y le sumo 6 de ese mismo algo, tendré entonces 14 de ese algo,
esta variable que en este caso tenemos  "x" más 7 considerado como valor absoluto
y el 4 y el -4 quedamos que ya se fue.
Entonces pongamos nuestro símbolo de igualdad
y tendremos entonces
14 valor absoluto de "x" más 7 es igual a 2, si yo busco quitar este 14, lo que haremos es dividir
del lado izquierdo entre 14, dado que
este 14 estaba multiplicando,
así es que para quitar la multiplicación, dividiré.
Si lo hago del lado izquierdo, lo haré
exactamente del lado derecho,
por lo que nos quedaremos con valor absoluto de
"x" más 7, que será igual a 2/14.
Ambos números tienen como factor común el 2,
se pueden dividir tanto el numerador como
el denominador entre 2, con eso tendremos 1/7.
Voy a marcar la división aquí porque
vamos a seguir del lado derecho,
ahora tenemos que entonces, valor absoluto de "x" más 7 es igual a 1/7
y esto solo nos da dos posibles caminos,
si nosotros pensamos que tomamos el valor absoluto de "x" más 7...  lo marcaré aquí...
y este número nos dará 1/7, tenemos dos
posibilidades, que "x" más 7
sea igual al valor absoluto de 1/7 ó que
"x" más 7 fuese el valor absoluto de -1/7.
Y de esta manera despejaremos "x" será igual a 1/7,
aquí está sumando y para que nosotros
lo podamos quitar lo restaremos, menos 7,
7 enteros son 49/7, con lo que tendremos 1/7
menos 49/7 = -48/7
ó también podemos considerar que entonces
"x" será igual a -1/7... -1/7 y quitaremos este 7...
y como lo restaremos del lado izquierdo, también
lo restaremos del lado derecho,
7 enteros es igual a 49/7 y tenemos -1/7
menos 49/7 es igual a -50/7.
De esta manera la ecuación que veíamos complicadísima, donde teníamos factores,
valores absolutos y constantes, al resolverlo podemos llegar a algo tan sencillo como que "x"
es igual a -48/7 ó "x" es igual a -50/7.
Y esta es nuestra respuesta.